[Music]
[Music]
technically technically technically been
technic we were alive take me don't
we're live at 11 I was a 1 minute late
we're here but welcome to GameSpot live
today we're playing some of the best
fighting games available through the PS
now platform or service I suppose if you
didn't know Playstation now lets you
stream hundreds of PlayStation games on
your ps4 or PC plus you can also
download a collection of PS board games
such as blood-borne a fun classic and
until dawn you can learn more at PS now
calm we'll give you more details on that
later but for now what are we playing
first so I decided that we're going to
start with injustice cuz it's it's kind
of a cool show off of its boom it's the
the PlayStation 3 version of the game
and we're streaming this ones are
streaming so we're streaming this one
okay the other two games are gonna be
playing later on our games that you can
download straight to your console as if
there's Lee so we can show that yeah as
well which is awesome
alright which is good because we're
gonna do 30 minutes ish for each one 30
minutes ish of Mortal Kombat X we're
calm at eleven right around the corner
yeah yeah and then we're gonna finish
with Ultra Street Fighter 4 which i
think is actually still better game than
5 personally I agree I was playing a
little bit you can watch like remind
myself how the game plays and it still
holds up like graphically yep it still
holds up gameplay wise there's so many
modes and features and characters but
right now we're playing in justice are
you what are you doing here this is
versus we're throwing down this is it's
a press start I had to hit X lies so
many lies so that's not the thing with
playing quiz station 3 games you gotta
use the touchpad alright so we'll the
beat doubt continued today from
yesterday find out this is the run back
will I find a way to make it happen Ben
was practicing Street Fighter 4 this
morning I called him out I said not fair
not cool but it's all good
he was he was just getting theme songs
yes Newton dad blood-borne is amazing
speaking of blood-borne yeah that'll be
our next one in the kind of like bigger
PS now streams if you didn't know that
ones coming up March the 11th so in two
weeks time not next week but two weeks
I'll have a cool hangout comrade Grundy
on a Sunday or something something
doesn't you like repeat like cool poem
Oh crabs which ones block so yeah we
might want to do a button check cuz I
know that burger flip injustice crab I
need different body layout
Wow cuz I know black is is right no see
it should be anything maybe it's forget
that it's now that I'm here I'm holding
back here you can hold him back
yes there you go wait but that's another
realm game I don't know what's going on
yeah yeah let's let's do this thing
that chip dammit see it's it's we got to
remember how all these things work
oh no oh I use my power already know my
Kryptonian power it's all right it's all
good this is fine this is fine come on
there oh yes turn over what what links I
have my proper setup here you got it yes
that oh yeah
foot dive it's kind of like well it's a
little full oh here we go that's okay
Anna oh I have to do the following
oh I think it's I think the opposite
okay okay I think I got a combo see
making landing oh no
that's it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
I don't I don't like this you gotta hit
those ankles all right Eric place for
you huh I can't lose ruthless game Oh
God what's your toe secret these these
lilies I missed it nope oh I went over
and so definitely over that's fine
kazoo it's an absolute activation so I
could just do it whatever you're
grunting secretly the best character in
this game I don't know if it's actually
a secret though I gotta figure out X or
I can't be here what's down know what am
i doing I got it right okay all right
this is just the one I figured out he
exit that's not it look at me let me
shut her oh I'm gonna get scammed
I just want to knock you through the
wall oh my goodness it's not enough
there's only five seconds Chet I can't
I appreciate the wrong game no no
there's there isn't e^x you can totally
like it's this little enough yet they
call it enhanced or something I have
yeah because okay so the freeze breath
by Superman if you do be like enhanced
version actually freezes how dare you I
love that I love it so much that's the
whole reason why I picked him it's cuz
postgame Eric two wins K hey I had three
wins yesterday you get that right get
that right crime I had three three wins
I do like that like going from the
stream yesterday into this dream it's
kind of like a look the old ever run
back except in a different case except
in a different game hey scorpion
scorpions hanging home today and bein
broke saw some would say play Lobo soil
I'll give it a go not very good with him
Aquaman tried in shenanigans
I feel like Eric will be a batman player
I am about to play Batman they're doing
right Bob you're dang right I'm a Batman
actually calling out and injustice to I
was a Superman player just because it
was easier to get off the freeze yeah ex
freeze but or the enhanced freeze which
I can't seem to do to save my life I
thought it was holding right trigger
while doing it but or I could have been
in putting things wrong oh here's this
I've enjoyed so much attitude I put us
in the top right whatever it's a good
enough spot you don't need to see my
health it's me Bruce Wayne Oh Bob Rudy
yes we got that shotgun we did counter
I'm trying I try to play like an animal
fighter right now I'm dashing all over
the place come back here no I heard a
button half I wasn't enough interactable
to it I'm all about it howdy lightning
how's it going hope you're having a good
help everyone's having a good day it's
it's too soon okay back back to here
you're actually trying to remember
just floating hover cars they all go oh
hello what I was blocking him what it's
too big it's too much ah yeah yeah I got
to remember how to play background
attitude a bird egg oh how dare you my
dad
Oh pixel pixel death ran him over with
the band will be I was about to try if
he did it first
ah finished show us the trophies we're
in it he's basically later yeah right
both so much attitude
all right oh and two looking good here
we go
I clearly have the wrong shirt on or I
we haven't gone to that game yet
oh yeah yeah see I feel like Street
Fighter might be the one we're able to
kind of pull back in because how dare
you want a very valuable get you in
m'kay
in Mortal Kombat oh yeah you got some
smaller combat trip a little bit but not
really better than injustice that's for
sure we'll try mr. J get the the preview
board and he said he's acting with Lobos
yeah I know right
guys a mind gamer he's a mind game
possibly a hustler
he's a hustler oh he's just trying to
get us here but thank you guys all for
tuning into uh this place I should know
stream that's checking out what I can't
believe this just so Wilburn name is
Jonathan I just subscribe to channel
thanks John it's good to see it glad
you're here
okay we're already worried and we know
everything you know
I like how you do those out of the air
no no no no no no that's that's my thing
it doesn't matter cuz it comes on my
side yeah there's too much too much
smoke in this do you think I can block
the interaction one day all I'll land
that jump off the robot get on the other
side there we go Oh No say I don't know
what my special spent so long since I
played this game
ha ha Oh Oh yours is like a counter no
no no last-ditch effort teleport punch
ah suck Allah ah
The Joker's definitely dead now ok she's
definitely dead he's alive mr. J never
dies hmm
I don't know about that I like the
Joker's they did a really good job with
the Joker in a lot of these these
fighting games I really like him in was
it MK vs. DC like that that version of
him is really good like I miss Maureen
tries him Green Arrow
um I'll go if that's all someone say
Nightwing earlier so I'll do it I'll do
a Nightwing let's go to the aircraft's
hang out with the planes do it heck yeah
who's who I'm on the left and taze on
the right that's Ben I'm Erik oh yes
oh you think you're so cinematic you
know what happens to light ring and yeah
injustice universe now
so after this game he dies because he
trips in his head because I don't like
someone tries to throw him his his like
little time for things and he ends up
getting hit and throws him off balance
and he falls and hits his head our and
that's why there's no Nightwing that's
what we need
[Music]
get in there do the thing yeah guy by
hitting you with those really sharp arm
blades whoa
show's over Green Arrow cool move
reeking like spoon stick around I want
to do that back we're gonna do a Batman
vs Superman fight for sure
Oh so I was definitely hitting so hard
oh man I did not know that green arrow
super was long distance now I no no no
no it's it's been a long time since I
obviously didn't play that much
injustice I played a bunch of injustice
here I played a lot of injustice to all
right so what do oh is that for later
the Batman Superman Red Hood greater
than that way yes I agree do you want
you want Batman or Superman I don't care
you decide I feel like you you felt like
you're you're getting into Superman a
bit Saul but I've got to be the red Sun
you've got to be cool hat Batman
are there any bandwidth stat stats while
you're streaming I think there might be
a way to pull it up I haven't messed
with it too much though I can't recall
to be honest
fighting under huge missiles is very
unsafe it's true you never know they
could go off they could be duds though
they could oh okay alright somebody tell
me how to enhance move
oh my you're fighting me my house that
was your first mistake we're in kind of
single stage tourism just kick you in
the shin Superman okay so that is how
you do it okay so it is with with art
shoot you just got to do the timing
correctly that's supposed to be big
beeps how dare you try to lure me over
there I just want to I just want to do
the cool cool States transition thing
you know oh you know what okay yeah
you want a single battery yo the wrost
it really isn't like a in a smooth oh
it's it's slowly coming back not not
today
[Music]
I like it does catch you up in the air I
see you going up in the air and I'm not
I'm not here for it he knows my tactics
chat no oh my gosh dang it I always time
to write no place come them I learned my
dirty Superman tactics the old back
laser I can't believe this feel you last
at Wayne Manor in his joy hole like how
it should be oh you don't have
kryptonite boys that help somewhat
thankful Louis is that you can't believe
it we did it
who's a good fight though we did it whoo
you almost came back I was like if I
choke this one away I think I should
just walk off stream so the market value
of that house is definitely gone gray
fox I agree tell me can you bleed a
little bit I got the flash go on to
stroke it Oh
flipping colors how do you switch the
costumes well you hold press a square
it'll bring up the Titanes stroke
alright don't know how to play death
stroke I know he's a ranged character
though that's what I need right now day
one zone outs needed zone him out yeah
right Oh gorilla grodd's in the
background I see him hanging out how
much internet speed what you need to
play so smooth
it's hard to say because I haven't tried
on anything but the office international
look at all this stuff I got ya some
magic tricks tricks - it's kind of like
oh no my hat's gone mm-hmm what do you
do about this situation then no cheese
yet I'm sure I don't know him to do it a
trick I can pull out I'm sure there's
something I'm here for the double use
chat no dude you gotta take him where he
get him that's fine I understand it's
all good
yeah cause he lives and I can do any bit
of damage it'll be worth this type of
magic I'm gonna drop them
all the grenades oh that's okay we did a
lot of damage
Eric plays it like a peck you dang right
oh I got a teleport Haven realize they
call me cheese eat it
are you cheesy lemon are you playing on
pc no we're currently playing on a ps4
all right I played him just like I would
Deadpool in Marvel Marvel 3 that's makes
sense that's what I would've did
chimichangas pineapple surprise exactly
ooh wrong universe Oh who else do we
have here
you got Shazam that movies coming out
sooner that's true oh man what me we got
that girl she was pretty good I think
yeah she had done that like top tier one
point right she had that really good
move that just comes on nowhere which at
one go Wade didn't you just go Wade
there no wait is I am so non DC that's
fair wait is weight is definitely one of
these superheroes I need help chat Oh
black Adam all right we'll just wait
Green Lantern took it to the fortress of
solitude
hashtag cheesy tape sweep sweet cheese
oh we only have five more minutes of
this really that was really good m'kay
baby same studio same studio
it's Barbara Barbara right yeah play
Shazam I will get Suzanne next music
Erica we try Superman Ben will try
Batman we did that already actually and
Superman Juan barely wait is Esther
alright okay oh that's them all do it
exactly I think I said it like before
I'll just
see I see you see where that's going
what's a step cage that step kicks
pretty bird yep Electric loves to thank
you sure how do you like her
like a good quick all of them Oh
business get it get it get it yeah take
him up going down looks like that loose
that would hurt a lot so I waited then
plus latest desk job ah that's what I
thought
all right Black Adam versus Shazam I
wouldn't do that that'll be probably the
last one for this last one for yes we'll
head off in a mortal kombat yep into the
MK land MK X gon give it to you alright
who do you want did you want Black Adam
we're Shazam um I can do Black Adam it's
a pretty pretty cool guy like Adam cheap
I like glass Adam you'll see it's
probably better that you don't have pain
you have that knowledge typically - he
was good I'm pretty sure he's gonna want
to scientifically Atlantis is the
greatest stage in this entire game okay
if only for one thing with that that
tube that crosses the middle of it every
character can slide on and that is what
makes
I have returned I'm back Shazam oops I
thought every curate to start it on
their mind
Shazam that's done oh hello I've got see
those things are the dirty baby Shazam
[Music]
no I was waiting for someone do it
no don't water the waters mine no one
gets it now I meant to tell Boyd
yeah you got combos disorient you Oh God
Shazam Oh mmm Dyson look I turned into a
kids and turned back again so we gotta
catch up somehow like it need my lead oh
okay this is gonna be a heck of a thing
if I'm able to find a way to come back I
don't know if it's gonna work
holy cow thank God away I'm so tired of
you look at me at fighting games at
least this was more of a three to five
so yeah I see match my total from
yesterday all right
and we're only one game down yeah
actually what a game just tuning in we
are playing injustice via the PS now
service and now we're gonna move on to
Mortal Kombat 10 so that was via the
streaming service you can also download
games so Mortal Kombat's XL is one of
the games or Mortal Kombat X I guess is
one of the games you can download as
well and you can learn more about that
on PS now calm so go check that out on
to the next game yeah it's the next game
here I'm excited because I like that
they also lets you just straight-up
download games and they come with all
the DLC everything that's that's come
out for them it also worked out really
nicely because I had a save file from
back when this game originally came out
and so I have a whole bunch of stuff
already kind of going with it but yeah
I'm ready I'm ready for some Mortal
Kombat I'm ready - this is gonna be a
visual upgrade yeah John Luke and I
played this a little while ago
after they announced okay yes so I've
got I've gotten a little bit of practice
oh well I might not have gotten the the
stuff downloaded just you yeah you got a
red say I'm in alright I used to know I
wonder if it was just like I don't know
anymore
you know I might just I might hit the
button here to see if it'll be like oh
yeah you can't think like that here
switch it off really quick check
something real quick cuz I'm pretty sure
we did the the download for it
I better got to get these extra
characters hopefully if not no big deal
there's still a pretty big roster yeah
store I'm just gonna do Justin to tune
he's gonna go through the Downloads
shoot we got here thank you guys all for
tuning in though we appreciate it so
it's a great time yeah that's weird
yeah we're good either way added to
Dallas oh let's do that just to just
wanted Jason Voorhees yeah that's that's
what I'm here for
all right hi he said there's a fun
glitch in the pathway was here
the other ones are good doesn't matter
cuz the character I was always gonna
pick is here anyway Yanni
he'll never Johnny he'll never know yes
more combat exit is on PS now
you got to remember how to play this has
a block button yes this has a blog
button for sure so this is the fun thing
about jumping between fighting games is
trying to remember exactly how
everything works I used to know
brutalities I used to do staged
fatalities I don't anymore sad times all
I did for one year was cover Mortal
Kombat 4 GameSpot as my life so what do
you think this is gonna get ugly you can
get even uglier oh yeah I got my stunt
double going here to jump off a trees my
name is Johnny Cage
yeah yeah oh oh yeah yeah I'm the tree
again
okay little little different than
injustice yeah we're in it oh god no
jeong-hwan yeah
from downtown got so much range oh it is
enough Johnny what are you doing
[Music]
yeah oh whoa it's got everything
oh I forgot how to play my oh there was
you got enough to like SiC accent no
brutality I love it it's how you start
off the Mortal Kombat yeah that's that's
exactly even do easy fatality right
there for ya cheese how dare you how
dare you I'm tryin to try to do my sonic
Fox you know except I didn't do a good
job cuz I forgot how to shoot his guns
I'm gonna play some
oh yeah you know you got to do it ah see
let's see if I figure if I remember I'm
so glad you did it I did it on accident
to be honest I feel like that's when
brutalities are at their best when you
don't intend to do them and they just
kind of happen out of nowhere yeah I'm a
important poor Johnny Cage New York
still got it I guess so Lord Rayden you
overreached in challenging I merely hope
to learn from you take you that I'm
blind but I'll take you out I'm ready
for it
oh I forgot you got ghosts
your sword boys it's perfect as it gets
the entire speech alright I gotta figure
out how to combo into that I got a box
for you
get out of here really quick
[Music]
yeah yeah I forgot that's how you run oh
yeah oh I'll give all right
in the air
oh no oh there was a helicopter no
that's still oh you come with over 47
percent not what this twins Luffy I used
to be able to it's been a while on
either my muscle memory is not there
anymore so yeah if you see a five to six
eight common well that's already pretty
good yeah
can anyone join no not today Salma do
you know we're probably just gonna be
fighting each other today but they do
play games with the community on
community Fridays Ben and John Luke I'm
not good with Kung Lao but I'll supposed
to do the spin move the spin spin all
the time to launch people up the cove of
the sky temple where will we go go to
the car
koves got a good one Kuryakin
technically we working we're like on the
cove in the training room but we do got
to do a subsea reversal scorpion it's
that way because that we did
try to remember the most important moves
excited into a single one with Johnny
Cage
yeah I'm not even doing this like oh
yeah that's okay okay square I just
realized I don't have ultra minutes I've
been trying to do like the street
fighter inputs but they're not there
sure put your hat away
running every time no you gotta remember
the spin move
so then I said on signal doing it right
I got the I got the other one down I
think it's like forward like that
[Music]
[Music]
no no it does so much damage though
[Music]
my goodness
they're just actually I do oh okay okay
that works okay you'll be okay you'll be
okay
sometimes you can look you can feel you
can feel those sometimes
oh okay do you need to change or even
put things
oh there's only one easy fatality left
I've been using them all that's fine I
think I can do it from here right here
yeah
so basically better telling me he's been
playing with the handicap this whole
time she was like Molina yeah see cool
hot turkey nose let's see if I remember
her combos though I don't think I do
it's good let's get keno going in here
yeah commandos cut through I've never
used a laser on if the commandos learn
that I always go via yellow on
I don't like look around to make sure I
was picking the other ideal
I'm very excited for moral comment 11 I
am - okay that time I need to see how
the fatal blows work it's basically like
x-ray but you only get one for the whole
thing I think so you can't just have it
for two rounds Melina Millie get out of
here sweeps that's a [ __ ]
Oh like just got x-ray
I was actually spamming x-ray in noob
saibot nk9
blowing see it was really nice to come
here
I know your chance to fatality pressing
my buttons can't believe this I tried to
do her x-ray and it didn't come out it
would hit to probably is there character
your professional wit no Molina was my
closest shot at it back in the day I
don't remember very many combos in its
yeah it's been a long time I haven't got
a chance
gotta kind of bring yourself back up on
it you know you okay with Jackie you
know I do what I want to do this up
versus corpse yeah which one would eat
anything
oh I'll go I'll go sub-zero do the
classic ski to really really crazy oh
there you go infrared scorpion chaser
[Music]
now say I hope we go to the woods cuz
that's just gonna be the reveal trailer
oh is that what it is
yeah the reveal trailer was that yeah I
remember fighting each other in the
woods she or I you dog Oh God no more
honor than you deserve
ling-ling - I was gonna say you do get
you got teleport right away
[Music]
Hey yep
did you can't not teleport a scorpion
that's that's like the number one we're
always abt always been teleporting man I
wanted through the log and power up
stuff that I needed to throw the log
[Music]
no I do it was coming I wanted you I
needed you lying to x-ray so I wasn't
gonna teleport I was like oh this is
just like it's literally just the
trailer redone
we did it show me that tongue damn it's
good all right we have nowhere Easy's so
if you're gonna do it you oh you have
one you have one so if you're gonna do
it we're gonna have to hit start to look
it up that's fine right now I'll play
Takeda even though I'm not sure so we've
gotten any any of these cool guest
characters yet I was okay with that was
never good prior to predator it was too
hard for me yeah alright a couple more
matches and we'll be moving on to some
ultra cheap spider school classic Street
Fighter he didn't know we're playing
well this one's not being streamed
through the PS now service but we were
playing a justice service have you seen
the bug where he is unbreakable and like
you can get rid of leg yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that metal sound for the machete smell
real good that's some that's the ticket
okay
get down
[Music]
that's it drive hold for respectable
right yeah that 90 is really good next
job Sturridge
anyway love it when characters regular
movies basically that was gonna work
maybe there's like a different condition
for it or something I don't like yeah I
wasn't too big seen some pretty crazy
stuff with him all right probably the
last matching list it's a quick one for
Mortal Kombat yeah there's a Jackie
oh I think I might you'll do her Mac I'm
actually a cool guy yeah I got a cool
guys there's some Quan Chi one she's got
some pretty cool things sound effects
are very wet
thanks cyborg man oh yeah there's no lie
there oh yeah lady oh predator huh it's
like prayers too hard all right we're
good Jackie oh boy I kill I can't oh I
was morally hard on you Thanks
yeah I think I put you go to the corner
with my bow right oh shoot I'm so sorry
oh no yes there we go that's it we did
it
the perfect way to send off is it a
certain part of the map that's an
uppercut I think it's I think it's
anywhere I'm not sure though I don't
know it should be anywhere evil and
stupid
oh my god you're headstrong oh my neck
let's go ahead
the dough the egg shotgun Hey look at
cinder in the background hanging out
chilling
[Music]
right oh okay
feeling
[Music]
I'll take take
[Music]
whoa with a breaker oh and I see I
already doing it building do it huh
another day I think has to be like on
the edge yeah
all right well Jane that was Mortal
Kombat thank you guys all for tuning in
and guys and gals if you didn't know we
are playing well we just played through
injustice earlier we've now played
through Mortal Kombat 10 we're about to
play Street Fighter 4 all sponsored by
PlayStation now you can check out more
of that via PS now calm if you're
curious some games are streaming some
games you can download you know
obviously it's up to you you know
download kind of cuts out the whole like
having a stream it but you can stream
certain games last week we played Metal
Gear yeah we did that was a fun one it's
a very good time top top streams yeah
MKX is on PS now so if you didn't know
that
go play should be out at least Odin skip
drummer your how how I treat butter for
was
I remember how fight your opponent I
love P fighter 408 to play the cabbage
yeah I saw 25 and
Europe for slippery crafters are not
about code start playing it was gonna
say I got to I got too excited - I got
you button change controllers Dudley
where's Doug Leon Street Fighter 5
[Music]
first where's Dan ass get him out of the
tutorial put him in the game
[Music]
[Music]
wrath of the raping demon this is the
best possible point stop
oh are you guess that's the hype man oh
my god put some clothes on Dan I hope
you're ready for a beating you put some
pants on maybe start yeah I think it's
it's fine for me the way it is this
weird I didn't know that you had this
unconventional setup yeah good yeah
oh man this way different plane
[Music]
we have that there's tax
good
[Music]
yeah yeah no it's kind of hopefully you
might have just been like oh I got him
with that there's no way always be
playing smart I gotta remember his palm
bozo
[Music]
got the announcer in this game is so
nuts
[Music]
you don't see me like that every day
folks like the man said where's Toki doh
oh the murderface the baby-faced
murderface killer oh yeah we got too
excited
the hi conduits we got to me I got to me
die 1,000 deaths
don't be an Akuma stroke how dare you
how dare you talk about her that way
oh yeah pecan baby we want to oil it up
the best the best secretly hi to your
carrot or evil ruler is the pain - I
never really played him though still in
there what happened - el fuerte look we
ain't Oh snot oppress everything he's
there down here
I mean like in get all these really cool
characters
I think that's the one from the alpha
then you see me hiccup climb through PS
now so far not really done a little bit
of a slight hitch turning Augustus but
it's very it didn't like persist it was
like one second otherwise it's been good
yeah I haven't felt any latency anything
well we have good internet so I'll
preface it with that let's begin oh look
at you so nice and proper yeah
this last choice hell yeah that plumbers
here here to clean up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the most important button to
remember was Dudley and I've done it so
I've already won
[Music]
everything is so glass game Hey Oh gets
a little Punjab that plunger poke I
think it's like all right
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
although I thought you doing hired
oh no oh get plundered it's right just
do a warm-up third time's the charm
we got this I'm playing smile so plunger
rific relent oh I guess do it's it's the
only way to play
[Music]
[Music]
hmm so many choices
[Music]
we're gonna do this for uh for oh no oh
man
but more colorful than what yeah this
game had great presentation strong art
style the gameplay was fluid gameplay is
fun right like oh yeah I'm a Shoto these
are stuff like then best friend
[Music]
Oh
Oh with that the light touch my little
foot oh man
the toes I do
I understand Blanca I get it now
[Music]
[Music]
it's not gonna work he's fly over you
real quick why I should have waited look
there's no way to his pill hold on to
that and keep that electricity going for
that long I was looking I was learning a
trade at that point dang as the
responsiveness feel it feels pretty good
here but this one's downloaded right so
this is downloaded straight up super
glass cannon even a Honda isn't in five
[Music]
I'll be gamer B oh man
you're playing the yeah so somewhere
later I was like oh you're Hagar you're
picking the other like we tie your tie
guys diverting my interesting Iowa
hey we could have that's one of the
games you could play as a fighting game
plays whoo oh my lord your cat yeah
that's a hell of a costume got an ass
I'm uncomfortable
[Music]
oh man I botched that real bad Oh
[Music]
very stratified - my my my match like
Tiger for wheel
[Music]
[Music]
I know you have a you know it's not safe
you're you're in I'm like do a I'm like
it's his spring safe she had it saved I
didn't press a that time in say rematch
one of us oh right
where's Rufus said I'm not any good with
him let alone some Jay Wong right here
Big Bang symphony
it's a guess fr4 surely better than five
it better than five Americans watching
for more there's more chances for faces
traffic focus attack and focus cancel
and stuff like that
what are you some of these costumes I've
never seen now try the best my little
pigtails yeah
a little I think it's the end
I get real real oily
sure you can
oh no that messiahs method light in that
favor the slide is good sign is fun my
sidekick definitely lands in there all
charged
oh nevermind hit a button
I have an idea what is it all Rufus we
guys do another fighting life game boy
at some point I am Spidey yeah fun games
are a little bit like I said if you guys
want to play with Ben and John Luke you
can check it out on Fridays with me
fellas when we play with y'all they put
jury and changed her a bit though ya
don't need that negativity man see you
later
I don't know how to play Oni that well
but he's a weird guy me go go hah goes
if you guys are just tuning in we're
kind of at the tail end of our sponsored
PlayStation now screen we've gone
through three fighting games now we
played injustice earlier we played well
combat 10 nano playing Ultra Street
Fighter 4 thank you all for tuning in if
you want to learn more about PlayStation
now go to PS now calm as mentioned we
have one more and a big sponsored PS now
screener would play blood 1 I want to so
anime I'm super saiyan your your
finishing move is the most animated
yup that's a cross up
Oh
[Music]
the löwe with me
[Music]
[Music]
some of the skins is first Street
Fighter Gallo with a wild fire
[Music]
oh this holding its breath
accidentally
I'll take the one with nothing is this
ultra deep it's not oh man
[Music]
[Music]
no God
of course anime wins
let's have a caricature it's just weird
that we're how many seasons in the DLC
characters and they I don't know there
we've got some interesting choices for
driver thirsty they are old friends
yeah yeah okay characters it like you
introduced really cool people in Street
Fighter for that you just didn't decide
to carry on the five where to
Oh
[Music]
the sir it's good since we do the girls
the other day I don't know what to do
he's got armor and he just kept doing
like the 360 grab them yeah like this
damage is real oh great and I got to get
in with birthday jumping all in place
it'll be fine there's almost like that
semi introduced oh my
[Music]
oh right on the wall
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right into love lat great these animal
costumes are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yep brought that elbow down brought the
people's elbow I got one was it was six
games unanswered that I had to pick gat
me this boy make it a bull boy to bull
market I guess so I don't know cowboy
canyons I own over I know which ones
cowboy can really try to get the run
back pac-man bull bull jheri curl
[Music]
no time
[Music]
where's violent canet but that's what
everyone else to know true come on
Street Fighter fans that's pretty good
dang it some type of eagle you know the
great American ho
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
he's here too careful
[Music]
this is a jam though I think Ken's
always had that the best best
[Music]
you know we got to break that airplane
thing right gotta break that wing off
get there would know we get to it I
don't know no time for one more then one
more yeah it's a one for all of them
yep all right there's so many good
choices
[Music]
so I'm not really good at FAQ scenes so
Hossein I can't really extent poverty
never been great at it
try to be more of a bundle fundamentals
kind of player mainly because I can't
execute on the
the coolest thing I can do with the
focus pack is bogus hack is - after it's
not throw that's pretty good shell
damage Oh training oh this is Jam this
is the same as Sakura theme
it's got piano to let you know that it's
business
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I shall follow zangief's hanging out the
back you know it's party
Oh supposed to follow it up with this
and it
[Music]
yeah damned it's at least a moment and
that's what matters
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I take the one round you got me there
I'm feeling the pressure though
[Music]
all right into it
secure just yeah I was waiting for it
okay
[Music]
no there's the combo the put down on the
street fighter game he'll be good one
day it was right daddy's not very all
right thank you all for tuning in to
today's stream sponsored by PlayStation
now with Playstation now you can stream
hundreds of ps4 ps3 and PS to games
directly to your console or PC with new
games being added every month MKX I
think was one of those newer games
edition now same with Metal Gear
HD collection in addition you can
download a collection of ps4 games onto
your console to play it anytime which
supports titles like blood-borne until
dawn or honor and pray and even more
wall or more go to PS now calm anyways
yes it was a fun salty runback today you
will dominated me an injustice handily
then you brought it back in and then I
got a can-am K in Street Fighter so
we're like two two right oh yeah killed
me in Dead or Alive
you killed me in a justice and then I
have to you have to wear nice it's good
yeah yeah stalemates good thing when you
play any anime fighters
I probably would've got killed unless
those BlazBlue in which I can kind of
hang there would be a neuron over here
would be a little tougher for the new
yeah it has like similar mechanics but I
I definitely played more BlazBlue
think'll you anyways yeah until next
time stay in school don't be a fool stay
in school played long and rough
employers a later day go by
[Music]